ptu
voici un jeu vidéo baptisé mouse ni
anglais ni américain ce jeu et français
son auteur laurent montaron lycéen de 14
ans nous allons suivre laurent pendant
sa journée de travail pour voir si un
auteur de jeux vidéo français est un
écolier comme un autre ou alors si
laurent est un peu déjà exceptionnel une
sorte de prototype de la génération
micro celle qui a grandi avec
l'ordinateur comme d'autres comme nous
ont grandi avec la télévision ou encore
la radio ou la voiture ou le téléphone
je m'appelle laurent montaron j'ai 14
ans je suis en seconde vient d'entrer au
lycée je fais de l'informatique depuis
quatre ans et départ ma petite chatte et
j'ai une faim je suis dans une famille
très nombreuse cinq enfants
laurent quel est le jeu avec lequel vous
jouez lors ce moment c'est fini un petit
jeu j'ai fait que j'ai vendu à une
société
ça se présente comme en parcourant 1 je
vois ça rapporte pas beaucoup mais ça me
permet d'acheter mon ordinateur
la cassette vous avez en main c'est
votre jeu wii
comment s'appelle ce jeu là c'est le
jackpot
un jeu assez classique c'est vous qui
l'avez écrit absolument
ça veut dire quoi exactement écrivain
jeux sur ordinateur ben d'abord il faut
avoir une idée bien entendu puis ensuite
il faut construire le programme nous
parle ligne ajouter des jt graphique
bien présente et où bat montrez-nous un
programme
celui ci voit si franck jackpot que j'ai
écris moi même ligne par ligne qui en
tient moins basique ou presque vous
voulez dire qu'en apprenant le langage
basic on peut déjà écrire des jeux wii
par exemple comme le mont premier
programme est fini pour fête des langues
étrangères ou au lycée oui allemande les
latins est-ce que ça sert à quelque
chose d'apprendre une langue étrangère
en informatique
oui ça peut servir nous avons à peu près
les mêmes structures ans l'attaquant
basique par exemple de locutions latines
ça correspond à une boucle en basic une
boucle en basic oui for next me for next
d'anglais donc c'est une basique
depuis tout petit il a été très attiré
par les chiffres toutes les nouveautés
et puis je crois aussi que ses frères
qui sont scientifiques aussi et l'ont
beaucoup aidé dans un mail à il avait
déjà un environnement prédisposant je
crois oui
il a des grands frères qui sont là et
physiciens de vote électronicien et
ingénieurs donc ça comporte quand même
des études plus poussées
là dans ce domaine là ça l'à beaucoup de
glee fait beaucoup de sport je vois des
coupes derrière vous non non ça c'est
mes frères enfin j'ai fait du ski oui
j'ai déjà remporté mon chez-moi de
bronze mais sinon je suis pas très axé
sur sport parce que vous êtes un bon
élève en classe
voilà une question bien indiscrètes
enfin oui ça peut aller
enfin mon but mon premier but un téton
mais il paraît que je pourrais faire
mieux
qu'est ce que vous allez faire plus tard
et en second du centcom in motion
les prochaines je veux prendre une
première sc première scientifique puis
je compte faire mon métier dans
l'informatique de jeux vidéo a forcément
peut-être des jeux plus quelque chose
d'un peu plus sérieux pour le bien de
tout le monde
qu'est ce que vous pensez du fait que
son âge on vend déjà un produit qu'on a
fabriqué avec ses mains et sa tête comme
un écrivain je crois qu il l'a fait
parce que ça lui plaisait donc ce qui
est agréable c'est que c'est une
nouveauté et puis qu'il inventait les
mêmes ça c'est déjà une bonne chose
sur son premier ce qui fait non je
regarde les jeux bien sûr les petits
jeux électroniques tout le monde s'y
intéresse mais
disons que dans le domaine plus poussée
la composition des programmes là je ne
me situe pas à intéresser le basique un
petit peu mais pas beaucoup
[Musique]
ça c'est le relais de l'espace
et encore un jeu des idées des projets
laurent on en à plat ce qui lui manque
déjà
c'est le temps de réaliser mais vous qui
regardez ces jeux d'un oeil critique ou
amusé qui certainement ne savait pas
inventé réaliser un jeu vidéo en
basiques comme laurent qu'en pensez vous
comment prenez-vous l'arrivée de cette
génération micro de ces écrivains
nouvelle mode qui ont troqué le stylo
pour le clavier ou la puce
ah j'oubliais les passions de laurent
sont la pêche l'astronomie la collection
de pièces de monnaie enfin juste après
sa petite chatte
[Musique]